mr president of the general assembly
excellencies
the fighting in ukraine must stop
it's raging across the country from air
land and sea
it must stop
now
russian missile and their bombardments
have been pounding ukrainian cities day
and night
the capital kiev is encircled from all
sides
in the face of the continuing attacks
kiev's 3 million residents are being
forced to seek safety in their homes
improvised bomb shelters
and the city's subways
the ukrainian government has distributed
a meaningful number of arms to the
population with the stated objective to
participate in the defense of the
country
according to nhcr half a million
ukrainians have fled across the
country's borders
although russian strikes are reportedly
largely targeting ukrainian military
facilities
we have credible accounts of residential
buildings critical civilian
infrastructure and other non-military
targets sustaining heavy damage
this escalating violence which is
resulting in civilian deaths including
children
is totally unacceptable
enough is enough
soldiers need to move back to their
barracks
and leaders need to move to peace
civilians must be protected
international humanitarian and human
rights law must be upheld
the sovereignty independence and
territorial integrity of ukraine
within its international recognized
borders must be respected in line with
general assembly resolutions
mr president we are facing a tragedy for
ukraine but also a major regional crisis
with potentially disastrous implications
for us all
yesterday russian nuclear forces were
put on high alert
this is a chilling development
the mere idea of a nuclear conflict is
simply inconceivable
nothing can justify
the use of nuclear weapons
mr president
we face what could easily become
europe's europe's worst humanitarian and
refugee crisis in decades
with the numbers of refugees and
internally displaced multiplying by the
minutes
i am grateful for the compassion
generosity and solidarity of ukraine's
neighbors who are taking in those
seeking safety
it is important that this solidarity is
extended without any discrimination
based on race religion or ethnicity
the neighboring countries will need all
our support in the days and weeks to
come
the united nations will continue to
assist with these efforts
mr president on saturday i spoke with
president zielinski and the sure dean
that united nations would not abandon
ukrainian people and convey our
determination to enhance humanitarian
assistance
even before the event of the past week
the u.n was providing some 3 million
people on both sides of the contact line
with humanitarian assistance
the united nations is now working 24
times seven
to access humanitarian needs
and scale up the delivery of life-saving
support to many more people desperate
for protection and shelter particularly
women and children elderly people and
those with disabilities
we are fully committed to staying and
delivering for everyone affected by this
deadly conflict across the country
some of our personnel are expanding
existing programs and others are
preparing new operations to get help to
those who need it fast
i want to highlight three concrete
actions first
i've allocated 20 million us dollars
from the central emergency response fund
to support emergency operations along
the contact line in the eastern oblasts
of donetsk and lewanska and in other
parts of the country
these will allow us to help more
vulnerable people get the basics shelter
food water and health care
as soon as possible
second
i have appointed amin award as the event
crisis coordinated for ukraine
he will liaise with the government and
with all relevant actors on the ground
supported by the resident and
humanitarian coordinator and the u.n
country team
at the same time we are bringing
together partners in and outside the
country and surging personnel into the
country
third
tomorrow we will launch two coordinated
emergency appeals for ukraine and the
region
one that addresses escalating
humanitarian needs inside the country
including rising internal displacement
and another that responds to the needs
of people crossing international borders
to seek refuge in countries neighboring
ukraine
as we ramp up our efforts it is
essential that the safety and security
of un and associated personnel in
ukraine are protected in accordance with
international law
and that humanitarian access to
vulnerable people and communities is
guaranteed
i call on all sides to uphold their
obligations for our freedom of movement
of humanitarian personnel and to
facilitate safe rapid and unimpeded
passage of humanitarian relief
i also urge the international community
to mobilize in support of our funding
appeals to address the needs of all
those displaced by this crisis
as well as other vulnerable groups whose
numbers will only grow as the fighting
escalates
mr president
humanitarian aid is vital
but it is not a solution
it is simply treating the worst impacts
of the conflict
the only true solution is peace
the attack on ukraine challenges
international law and the multilateral
system rooted in the u.n charter
some of the possible consequences of a
worsening conflict are terrifying to
contemplate
regional tensions are rising
the latest security measures underline
the high stakes for all
the economic repercussions of the crisis
will have widespread impact
and i count on every member step to live
up to the principles of the charter
mr president
the guns are talking now but the passive
dialogue must always remain open
it's never too late to engage in good
face negotiations and to address all
issues peacefully
i hope that the direct talks now taking
place between ukrainian and russian
delegations
will produce not only an immediate ult
to the fighting but also a pass towards
a diplomatic solution
i welcome and encourage all peaceful
efforts to end the bloodshed and all
this conflict
i thank the countries who have offered
to also facilitate negotiations
the united nations is ready to support
such efforts
mr president
war is not the answer
it is death human suffering
senseless destruction
and then immense this
senseless destruction and an immense
destruction from the real challenges
facing humanity
the climate crisis and biodiversity loss
vitally needs socio-economic recovery
from the pandemic
healing the divides of race and gender
and so many other pressing 21st century
challenges
humanity cannot afford to be locked in a
mindset that dredges up the worst of
past centuries
we need to look forward as united
nations to overcome the scourge of war
we need to focus on solving problems not
making them worse
in cities around the world people are
taking to the streets and then demanding
an end to war
people in ukraine want and need peace
and i believe people in the russian
federation do too
we need peace
now
thank you
i thank the secretary general for his
statement
i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative of
ukraine
so
mr president
secretary secretary general
for the first time since
the united nations
was born
there is a full-fledged war in the
center of europe
everyone in this whole
and everyone in the world
knows
that russia
and russia alone
started this invasion
now facilitated by belarus
this war was not provoked
it was chosen by someone who is right
now sitting in the bunker
we know what happened
with the person who sat in the bunker
in berlin
in may 1945
before i continue with my formal
statement
i would like to switch to russian and
invite you to put on the
headphones
because i would like to read from the
screen
shot of the
smartphone of a smartphone
of a killed russian soldier
there's an actual screenshot from
someone who is dead already
are you really
in during training exercises especially
i'm not in training sessions
where are you then
whether i can send you a parcel
what kind of a parcel
is a real
even targeting civilians
throwing themselves under the wheels and
not allowing us to move
they call us fascists
mama this is so hard several moments he
was killed
and this was several moments before he
was killed
imagine if you want to just visualize
the
magnitude of the tragedy
you have to imagine
next to you
next to every name plate of every single
country
in this general assembly
more than 30 souls of killed russian
soldiers already
next to every name
of the every single country in this
assembly
30 plus killed russian soldiers
hundreds of killed ukrainians
dozens of killed children
and it goes on and on and on
so just imagine those killed people next
to you
when you will listen to my formal
statement
big militarized powers seeking for
geopolitical greatness
has launched a full-fledged military
offensive against a smaller neighbor
aimed at invading the country
deadly airstrikes dropped on civilians
heads across the entire country and the
russian troops crossed ukraine's borders
from the territory of russia belarus and
the occupied parts of ukraine's donbas
and crimea
does it remind you of something doesn't
it
indeed
very clear parallels
could be drawn with the beginning of the
second world war ii
and the russia's course of action is
very similar to what their spiritual
mentors
from the third reich
employed
on the ukrainian land 80 years ago
just one
the most recent example
example of human sufferings
example of war crime
as all of us were on our way to the
general assembly today the russian army
shelled with grad multiple rocket
launcher systems the residential areas
of the city of kharkiv
the second biggest
in ukraine
innocent civilians have been killed and
wounded
the exact numbers is very difficult to
estimate because of the warfare while
the
negotiations are still underway
at the border with belarus
with the forexpress our gratitude for
overwhelming support that
made this decision
on the emergency session possible
we are grateful to the president of the
general assembly for his taking care of
this idea well in advance
we appreciate the
engagements engagement of the un
secretary general who has taken a very
strong stance in support of peace in
support of the u.n charter
we have been prompted to call for an
emergency special session as the level
of the threat to the global security has
been equated to the to that of the
second world war
or even higher following
putin's order to put an alert russian
nuclear forces what what a madness
if he wants to kill himself
he doesn't need to use nuclear arsenal
he has to do what he's saying what what
the guy in in berlin did in the bunker
in may
1945.
the security council addressed the issue
of the russian law against ukraine and
the decision was not adopted due to the
obvious reason
the country attempting to occupy ukraine
since 2014 has occupied the seat of the
of the council
permanent member since 1991.
therefore we do not accept the russian
logic
that the security council was unable to
act due to one-sided and unbalanced
approach the only guild tea party is the
russian federation
distinguished delegates
russia uses all its military potential
to attack ukraine and has begun
redeploying
reserve units on the border with ukraine
it fires crews and ballistic missiles at
cities
attacks with aviation tanks and
artillery sensor subversion and
reconnaissance groups which mark
residential buildings in preparation for
the air attacks
russia's missiles are now aimed at
destroying the infrastructure objects
they targeted the radioactive waste
disposal site near kiev
the fuel base in the town of vasil kiev
that is effectively a kiev's suburb
the objects of logistic infrastructure
including bridges airports and water
reservoirs remain among the targets
such towns as chester and stanislaus
canadia lugansk are now nearly destroyed
as well as residential buildings in and
around kiev and kharkiv
the russian forces seized the chernobyl
nuclear power station
at the part of southern herison region
including the north crimean canal
due to the active moving of
russian-heavy militaries through the
chernobyl exclusion zone the radiation
level has increased rapidly
in the black sea russian warships
deliberately attacked two civil vessels
under the flags of panama and moldova
approaching ukraine
these constitutes a flagrant violation
of the international law of the sea
incredibly
some one of the vessels had
the russian crew
still it was attacked by the russians
russians keep attacking kindergartens
and orphanages
thus committing war crimes and violating
the wrong statute
hospitals and mobile medical aid
brigades are also targeted by the
russian shelling
and the sabotage groups working in
ukraine cities and
towns the russian military fired
on ambulance crews in the areas of
zappoligia and kiev in akhtirka district
of
sumit
region russian tanks shot down a bus
with civilians
later the russian military does not
allow
did not allow ambulances
on the spot
as of today
352 people including 16 children were
killed
on the ukrainian side and 2040
ukrainians
including 45 children wounded
during the first five days of the
russian
invasion and this number is growing
non-stop i have already told about
the
morning shellings in kharkiv and we
cannot really estimate at this moment
how many were killed
in response ukraine has activated its
right for cell defense according to the
article 51 of the u.n charter
the russian troops are suffering losses
aircrafts helicopters tanks trucks
personnel
the aggressive forces have already lost
more than 5 000 in manpower during the
first days of aggression
excellencies
the general assembly should be vocal in
demanding from the russian federation to
stop its offensive against ukraine
in recognizing russian actions as an act
of aggression against a sovereign and
independent state
in demanding from russia to immediately
completely and unconditionally withdraw
its forces from the territory of ukraine
with within its internationally
recognized borders
in demanding from the russian federation
to reverse the decision related to the
status of certain areas of danielsk and
lugansk regions of ukraine in demanding
full compliance with the provisions of
international humanitarian law
the general assembly should also be
clear with regard to the treacherous
role of belarus and his involvement in
aggression of the russian federation
against ukraine
distinguished members of the general
assembly
what is happening now
in ukraine
has already had the security and
humanitarian implications for all of you
immediately for europe
a bit later for the rest including in
terms of food
security energy security financial
markets
collapse of the economies
last september
my president said while delivering his
statement
at the high level segment of the 76th
session of the general assembly
and i quote
i understand that criticism of the uan
is often
heard
but we criticize ourselves
end of quote
if we fail to respond now we will face
much more than criticism
we will face oblivion
it must not happen
now it is time to act
time to help ukraine
that is paying now the ultimate price
for freedom and security of itself and
of the world
if ukraine does not survive intention
survive international peace will not
survive
if ukraine does not survive the united
nations will not survive have no
illusions
if ukraine does not survive we cannot be
surprised if democracy fails next
now we can save
ukraine save the united nations
save democracy
and defend the values we believe in
and that ukrainians are fighting for
and paying with their lives
the russian delegate
will speak shortly
putin has done everything
to delegitimize
the russian presence in the united
nations
but i wonder
if the russian presence in the united
nations has ever been legitimate
i wonder
if ever
this whole this assembly
voted
in accordance with
paragraph two
of article four
on admission
of the russian federation
to the united nations
either
in accordance with
paragraph 2
of article 4
on admission
of the russian federation
to the united nations
either in december 1991
or
in january 1992
or wherever
thereafter
i want to ask
the delegates
whose countries
voted for admission of the russian
delegation to the united nations
to raise their hand
to confirm that russia was admitted to
the united nations according to the
charter
please gentlemen ladies and gentlemen
please raise
your hand
if your country voted in the formal
session of the general assembly
in reply to the letter by president
yeltsin dated december 24 1991 when he
told the united nations that russia
would like to be a continuator state of
the
demised soviet union
anyone
should i put my glasses if my vision
fails me and i don't see
any hand raised
any country
anyone voted for russian membership
i leave you with that
and think about it
when you listen to the russian delegate
i thank the distinguished representative
of ukraine
i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative
of the russian federation
[Music]
[Music]
and this definitively persuaded us of
the fact that we no longer have a right
to allow the residents of them
in so far as ukrainian provocations
against the people of dumbass in
february did not
sponsor
the leadership
ongoing the persistent aggressive
undertaken by the ukrainian regime
actively
armed and incited
and sponsors they would be able to
address the issues
militarily it is difficult otherwise it
would be difficult to explain the
ongoing intensification of shelling and
sabotage acts on the territory of the
republic which i mentioned the people of
donbass and luganza could continue to
have to take shelter in
their
turned a blind eye to this and they
merely echoed ukrainian tall tales about
the
allegations that
people were shelling on them
the worsening
the suffering of the residents
simply don't exist for that
took a decision for especially military
special military operations to be
carried out occupation of ukraine is not
part of this of these plans the goal of
the special operation is to protect the
people
who for elite years were subject to
torment
further will strive to hold accountable
those who carried out countless
council of the russian federation
ukraine
[Music]
or color
today's government of ukraine is no such
government certainly moreover during the
special military operation russia has
been exercising its right to
self-defense from a regime
that has been striving to
gain access to nuclear weapons the
president of ukraine exclusively stated
this
on 18th february during the munich
conference and this i would recall this
statement that he delivered was met with
applause by the participation of this
conference at the same time ukraine is
seeking membership in nato where there's
act uh article five in effect and as
territorial claims
by leveraging article 51 of the uh
russia is also seeking to uphold the
purposes and principles of the united
nations charter on the soil
and ukraine ensuring that the main goal
of the united nations be upheld
the very
negative role played in all of this by
western colleagues led by the united
states
instead of compelling kiev to comply
with its obligations
are not being complied with the russian
federation which i should like to recall
and emphasize
russian federation is not a party to it
moreover our western colleagues
inundated the country with weapons
have been sent to the country
um instructors and effectively incited
who are facing a 120 000 strong military
contingent
prompted them to engage in armed
provocation against
this thereby
[Music]
ukraine and georgia will join
nato and this was a met this was
portrayed as some kind of a great
compromise
it was immediately met
plans undertaken in ukraine and georgia
to join uh the alliance at the same time
in
2014 there was a brutal
constitutional crew
which took place in kiev as a result of
which
and their policy was to create an
anti-russia in ukraine and
ensure that it joined
nato and i will revisit that
infrastructure in that country
in december 2021 we propose that
agreements be arrived at with the us and
nato
for security assurance should be
provided to
the russian federation however our
extended height
unceremoniously rebuffed by americans
and nato representatives propose that we
propose that we continue to discuss
secondary issues
without consideration of our concerns
moreover
the question was not addressed
how the freedom of choosing alliances
aligns with the principles of
indivisibility or securities which is of
great importance to us probably many of
you wonder what should be done now and
what kind of role the united nations
play in addressing the ukrainian process
ukrainian crisis we believe that the u.n
can and should play its role health to
bring the stakeholders positions closer
together and to eradicate the causes of
conflict the key role here
should be played by and
alive
in this document there's no need to
explain why
it's suffice to
have a cursory glance at the document
why is it anti-ukraine in the document
because this document beyond any doubt
is inconsistent
now the main reason for our negative
vote was
then they would not have left out issues
that need to be addressed in the context
of the ukrainian issue specifically
areas with artillery pieces and multiple
rocket launchers and uh reigning bombs
on the people of dunbar's missions
with the
tolerance and indulgence of western
sponsors
consistently and cynically
sure their obligations to implement the
minsk agreement at the same time at the
line of contact ukrainian
death squads
the
fact that um
investigation into these tragedies
the maidan regime was deliberately
exposed
at the same time the perpetrators of
tragedy are well known they are
flaunting their presence
[Music]
to carry out any actions or steps
[Music]
[Music]
murdering political opponents
persecuting opposition
shattering opposition television outlets
um
which were then turned on
peaceful civilians in denmark the
responsibility for what is taking place
right now
misinformation from the ukrainian armed
forces
our military operation as a result
of negative consequences
[Music]
[Music]
is
and they're using them they're hiding
themselves behind them and using them as
human shields
abundant evidence from ordinary
ukrainian nationalism
and multiple rocket launchers in
residential areas this is an egregious
violation of international humanitarian
laws
effectively this is the same tactic that
is being used by isil terrorists all of
the responsibility for the possible
repercussions of ukraine are also
threatened by
unfettered uncontrolled uh radical
elements giving to all of those foolish
including
criminals who have specifically been
released from prison they are now
receiving weapons and the looters and
monitors and criminals are now using
them to target civilians that there are
sufficient and abundant evidence for of
this from residents
a human right
in ukraine and how it has been and
continues to be
in uh at the state level i briefly quote
today
the apogee of the
recklessness in ukraine was that
criminals have been released from prison
they have carried out
grave crimes murders
etc
willing or received 25 000 machine guns
without any documentation
a young girl two children are in
hospitals
the former acting
president
following the unconstitutional crew in
february
throughout the territory of the country
and this is despite the fact that the
most recent course
of documentary ukraine in 2019 is
of destruction of civilian
infrastructure
by a russian military does not exist
ukrainian uh uh attacks and uh
and uh accidental uh attacks
uh
bear on the fact that ukrainian
nationalists are carrying out this
violent social networks have
training manuals about how to create
fakes to retain our military operations
ukrainian social networks there are 1.2
million such
is
at an attempt
regardless of our western partners
attempts to avoid this
disregarded our legitimate concerns in
connection with nato policy and western
countries
breach of the core principles of the osb
on indivisibility
and all of those who are dissenters and
russia is seeking to end this war thank
you
i thank the distinguished representative
of the russian federation
so
i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative of the
european union
mr president
i have the honor to speak on behalf of
the european union and its member states
north macedonia montenegro albania
bosnian herzegovina
iceland norway
republic of moldova georgia san marino
andorra monaco and liechtenstein align
themselves
with this statement mr president i want
to thank you for convening us here today
and for the secretary general to be here
and for all of you colleagues being here
it's very important that the facts are
heard
and fully understood
and that this body is able to take the
appropriate decisions
after the fact that the security council
thanks to the
veto by one country alone
stopped this council from taking that
decision
let me start by expressing the european
union's full solidarity and support to
ukraine and its people who are
courageously fighting an unprovoked and
unjustified military aggression from
russia
since our meeting here in the general
assembly last week the situation has
dramatically escalated
despite tireless diplomatic efforts
including at the highest level
russia has decided to turn its back to
peace
to the rules-based international order
as defined inter-alien the u.n charter
to diplomacy and to the international
community
russia's military attack against ukraine
has already caused an alarming number of
deaths
injured in internally displaced and
refugees
we condemn in the strongest possible
terms the unprovoked invasion of ukraine
by armed forces of the russian
federation
in violation of ukraine's independence
sovereignty and territorial integrity we
also condemn the involvement of belarus
in this aggression against ukraine and
we call on both russia and belarus to
abide by their international obligations
we're also learned by russia's racing of
the nuclear alert level
we call on russia to de-escalate and to
immediately return to the previous alert
level of its nuclear arsenal and to
avoid any actions that could risk the
safety or security of the nuclear power
plants in ukraine a non-nuclear weapon
state under the nuclear
non-proliferation treaty
russia bears full responsibility for
this aggression and the resulting
destruction and loss of life we demand
from russia to seats seize its military
operations immediately and
unconditionally and to withdraw all
forces and military equipment from the
entire territory of ukraine within its
internationally recognized borders we
further call on russia to engage in
earnest in dialogue with the view to
political and diplomatic solution
russia's actions grossly violate
international law and are in clear
breach of the u.n charter and the osce
helsinki final act as well as russia's
specific commitments to respect
ukraine's sovereignty and territorial
integrity under the budapest memorandum
of 1994.
this is arguably the biggest aggression
in europe since the end of the second
world war
it follows similar russian aggression
against its neighbors in 2008 and 2014
we underscore our firm support for the
sovereignty and territorial integrity of
georgia and of the republic of moldova
and we are closely monitoring the
situation in the region
this assembly has a responsibility
immediately and effectively to
acknowledge and address russia's actions
failing to do so will erode trust to the
rules-based global order with the u.n at
its core
and the u.n charter itself it would send
the wrong message to perpetrators of
such aggression and aggravate similar
risks to other u.n member states in the
region and beyond
we stand firmly by ukrainians and its
people we deplore the loss of life and
human suffering this is a dire
humanitarian catastrophe and
humanitarian needs are rapidly
increasing with the toll of idps and
refugees rising humanitarian support is
a priority in the wider package of eu
support offered to ukraine in these
trying days
the units member states are providing
urgently needed humanitarian assistance
to the ukrainian population
ukraine has activated the union civil
protection mechanism and is receiving
urgently needed supplies from eu member
states in addition the republic of
moldova to which more than 60 000
ukrainians have fled has requested and
received eu humanitarian support in
dealing with the human catastrophe
caused deliberately by the russian
federation's invasion of ukraine
we call on russia and russia backed
armed formations to respect
international law including
international humanitarian law
civilians and civilian infrastructures
must be protected and humanitarian
access should be secured
we call on russia and russia backed
armed formations to allow safe and
unhindered humanitarian access
and stop their disinformation campaign
and cyber attacks
we strongly condemn the involvement of
belarus in this aggression against
ukraine and call on it to immediately
stop action and to abide by its
international obligations
recall our unwavering support for the
independence sovereignty and territorial
integrity of ukraine within its
internationally recognized borders and
we call on all un members not to
recognize the two
self-proclaimed separatist entities
the eu has reached reacted swiftly and
decisively to russia's recognition of
ukraine's self-proclaimed separatist
entities and the invasion of ukraine by
adopting restrictive measures we intend
to take such measures against belarus
mr president let us be clear on this
we firmly believe that the use of force
and coercion to change borders has no
place in the 21st century let us recall
that the u.n charter prohibits both the
threat and the use of force against the
territorial integrity or political
independence of any state or in any
other manner inconsistent with the
purposes of the eu united nations
tensions and conflict should be resolved
through dialogue and diplomacy the eu
together with like-minded partners have
been united in making unprecedented
efforts to achieve a diplomatic solution
but russia has not reciprocated these
efforts and instead opted unilaterally
for a grave and premeditated escalation
with this one-sided step russia is
further isolating itself we are today at
a crucial and historical moment
too many times in the past the
international community has been blind
or too slow in front of unfolding
tragedies
entire generations in many places around
the world many of you representing them
have paid and are still paying the price
of inaction
we cannot make the same mistake again we
have to take action
after russia's veto in the security
council last week the general assembly
has the responsibility to send a strong
and united message on the need for
russia to immediately and
unconditionally seize its military
operations
withdraw its troops and opt for genuine
dialogue we call on russia to avoid in
particular any action that places the
safety and security of ukraine's nuclear
and radioactive waste installations at
risk the people of ukraine and the whole
world are watching us and counting on us
and will judge us on the decisions that
we will take here in this special
emergency session
and it's our duty and responsibility for
all of us to do our utmost to defend the
u.n charter and the international order
we therefore hope that this assembly
will massively support the resolution
table by ukraine and its partners
the eu and its member states will
continue to do their utmost to protect
the integrity of the rules-based
international system which is key to our
collective security and we call on all
you and member states to do the same
on our side we will continue to stand by
ukraine support its democratically
elected institutions and representatives
and its people including through
additional political financial
humanitarian and logistical support i
thank you very much colleagues i thank
you very much mr president
i thank the distinguished representative
of the european union
so
now give the floor to the distinguished
representative of denmark on behalf of
the nordic baltic countries
i have the honor to speak on behalf of
the eight nordic baltic countries
estonia
finland iceland
latvia lithuania norway sweden
and my own country denmark
mr president on the night of 24th
february the russian leadership decided
to attack ukraine
let me be clear
we condem in the strongest terms
possible
the invasion of ukraine by the russian
federation
people around the world are watching
with horror
the tragedy unfolding in ukraine
a member state of this organization a
member of this community of nations
we are struck with a profound sense of
injustice and a profound sympathy with
the ukrainian people who are fighting
for their country
their cities their homes their families
their lives
their freedom and their future
the russian leadership aggression and
brutal armed attack
is in clear violation of ukraine's
sovereignty and territorial integrity
within its international recognized
borders
the russian leadership's actions greatly
violate international law
and the principles of the u.n charter
they are an attack
on this organization
and this cannot stand
last week
the russian leadership decided it will
raise ukraine's right to determine its
own future
this cannot stand
mr president
russia countered on the world to remain
silent but we are acting and on this day
and until peace prevails and every
ukrainian can safely return to their
homes we stand with ukraine
the devastating consequences of this
aggression not only for europe but
globally
cannot be overstated
russian aggression against ukraine will
have global and long-term negative
consequences challenging the rules-based
international order if we let it go
unanswered
in the time ahead
we fear increased suffering with
potentially large number of casualties
and extensive destruction of civilian
infrastructure
we see fighting unfolding in and around
urban areas and we are deeply concerned
about the long-term cumulative and
protracted harm to the civilian
population
mr president
we will continue to look at every single
instrument in our toolbox as a matter of
urgency
sanctions have already been enacted to
[ __ ] putin's ability to finance this
war machine
and likewise the role of the lukashenko
regime in belarus in enabling the attack
on ukraine also demands a firm response
nordic baltic countries have been
delivering financial humanitarian and
military assistance to the people of
ukraine
and many of our partners and friends
around the globe have joined us
every nation must look at how to further
support ukraine
mr president
during the days we have watched with
horror broadcasted images of families
separated children sheltering in the
safety of the kiev subway system
kindergartens destroyed by russian
ordinances and the ruins of bombarded
residential buildings in the center of
the capital of ukraine
we are outraged by indiscriminate
attacks on civilians in this unlawful
and immoral war of conquest that serves
no purpose and no principle but the
naked quest for power and territory this
cannot stand
russia must respect international
humanitarian law and human rights law
full and unhindered humanitarian access
must be guaranteed civilians must be
protected
we call on russia
to stop this census war and we echo the
plea of the secretary general we demand
an immediate ceasefire and we urge
russia to withdraw all its forces from
ukraine and return genuinely to the path
of dialogue and negotiation
mr president let me be clear
every civilian death
every war crime will be recorded and we
will
ensure that the perpetrators of these
heinous crimes are held accountable and
brought to justice
history has its eyes on us
every legal avenue available will be
used to hold the aggressor to account
ukraine has sent a request to the
international court of justice on
russia's erroneous and absurd
allegations of genocide in ukraine which
the russian federation
has cynically used as a full pretext for
its invasion
the international criminal court's
prosecutor has also noted that he is
monitoring russia's invasion of ukraine
and has jurisdiction to prosecute war
crimes and crimes against humanity
the prosecutor's office may and will
exercise its jurisdiction over and
investigate any act of genocide crimes
against humanity or war crime committed
within the territory of ukraine as
ukraine has accepted the court's
jurisdiction we fully support the icc's
monitoring of the situation
colleagues
the rules based international order
which governs how states interact with
one another
was put in place drawing from the
horrible lessons of two world wars
promising one another
that future generations would be saved
from the scorch of war
the attack on ukraine
the russian invasion
of ukraine is a direct
assault on the principles and purposes
of the u.n charter
this cannot stand
the matter is now in the hands of the
general assembly where one veto cannot
overrule the u.n membership where the
power and legitimacy
is manifested in numbers
russia's shameful use of the veto on a
matter it bears full responsibility for
is completely unacceptable
as a permanent member of the security
council russia has a special
responsibility for maintaining peace and
security
not to violate the very principles of
the u.n charter
the latest meetings of the council
demonstrated the need for reform it
demonstrated who had the firmness and
valor to defend the uncharted
no country can grow and thrive in
isolation russia knows this the general
assembly has the power to send a firm
message to putin and what we say today
and how we vote on the resolution
presented will make a difference on the
ground in ukraine and to the ukrainian
people they will be watching us
hoping that the world will come in on
the side of the u.n charter and our
promise of never again
colleagues russia's unlawful
and brutal armed attack on ukraine will
affect and impact everyone
and if we do not join our forces to turn
back this side today
we will be even less equipped to deal
with similar crises and crimes in the
future wherever
on whichever continent they occur
over the last week we have heard
powerful statements from representatives
of every continent on this planet from
africa to asia from europe to the
americas that russia's behavior towards
a fellow member of the united nations
cannot stand
and we will hear more today
and to those who still referred to two
parties to a conflict we echoed the
words of a protester who had written on
her sign
if russia stops fighting there will be
no more war
if ukrainians stop fighting there will
be no more ukraine
that is the simple reality before us
that is the symbol truth
the world will hold russia and belarus
accountable for their actions
russia is the main aggressor belarus as
the enabler i thank you mr president
i thank the distinguished representative
of denmark
i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative of france
mr president
[Music]
foreign
immediately
increasingly
is
[Music]
ukrainian
foreign
[Music]
yes
[Music]
resolution thank you
i thank the distinguished representative
of france
i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative of the
united kingdom
mr secretary general mr president
colleagues
on friday
81 member states
supported a resolution in the security
council
to stop the war in ukraine
russia
was completely isolated
in opposing that resolution
today
we gather in the general assembly
to stand against russia's illegal attack
on ukraine
and its assault on the principles of the
un charter
the facts are clear
russia has invaded ukraine
without provocation
and without justification
russia
has rained missiles and rockets
down on kiev
odessa and other cities
the brave men and women of ukraine are
enduring the barrage and have held their
cities from russian invaders
they are fighting for their country
for their continued future
as a free and independent nation
but the humanitarian consequences
are already immense
we hear of babies born in air raid
shelters
children with bomb craters in their
kindergartens
and today
news of the shelling of residential
areas in kharkiv
these are indiscriminate attacks on
ukrainian civilians
seven million ukrainians
are displaced
in short
the scourge of war
that our united nations was created to
prevent
has been unleashed
by russia on ukraine
the international response to russia's
aggression has been united
and swift
around the world and here in this
building
we must stand together
to defend the rules and enforce the
accountability
that we have built together
if we do not stand up for them now
then the safety of every nation's
borders and independence are at risk
that is why
we also condemn belarusian support for
russia's invasion of ukraine
as the secretary general said last week
russia's actions are violations of the
territorial integrity and sovereignty of
ukraine
and conflict directly
with the principles of the charter of
the united nations
and as he said today
the only answer is peace
so our message today is simple
we offer our unequivocal support for
ukraine and the ukrainian people
we call on president putin to stop this
senseless war
and we urge
all fellow members of the united nations
to speak up for ukraine
and to defend the charter
slava ukraine
i thank the distinguished representative
of the united kingdom
i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative of georgia
thank you mr president
my delegation aligns itself with the
statement delivered by the
representative of the european union
and in my national capacity i would like
to at the following comment
excellencies
we have gathered today in an emergency
session because the security council
once again failed us in acting as a
guardian of peace and security
so now it is upon us
the general assembly where we all have
equal rights to vote
to stand up and make it certain that the
united nations delivers on the purpose
it was created for
the use of armed force by a u.n member
against sovereignty territorial
integrity or political independence of
another member state violates article
2.4 of the un charter and constitutes an
act of aggression as defined by the
resolution
3314 of this very body adopted by
consensus
what we see in ukraine is an act of
aggression on the part of russia and we
condemn it
last week
i spoke from this very rostrum about
russia's pattern of behavior against its
neighbors
russia's full-scale military aggression
against my country
should have served as a wake-up call for
all
but alas it has not been possible to
prevent the similar scenario unfolding
few years later in ukraine
not to repeat myself let me just say
that we in georgia do know what the toll
of war is
we do know what is this disastrous
consequences and that is people innocent
civilians women and children who pay the
highest price
it is devastating not only for those who
live through it
but passes down to generations
let me be clear
core principles enshrined in the un
charter the helsinki final act the
charter of paris for new europe and the
commitments taken under the budapest
memorandum are non-negotiable nor
subject to revision by any country no
matter how large or powerful it may be
territorial acquisition through use of
force or a threat to do so
is illegal and impermissible
georgia calls on the russian federation
to immediately seize its military
activities and withdraw all its forces
and armaments from ukraine
allow immediate access to all
international humanitarian and human
rights mechanisms wherever is needed on
the entire territory of ukraine
reverse the decisions related to the
status of integral parts of ukraine's
donetsk and luhansk's regions and crimea
and to do so
the same with regard to georgia withdraw
forces allow humanitarian access reverse
the status related decision with regard
to the occupied
territories georgia was among the
co-sponsors of the draft security
council resolution that got vetoed
and we are the co-sponsors of the draft
general assembly resolution that is soon
to be considered
this resolution although it concerns
ukraine
is a watershed moment for all of us
and i would dare say for the future of
the rules based order and our united
nations
so i call on you to vote in favor of the
proposed draft
to vote to save the succeeding
generations from the scorch of war
to vote for the united nations
and in conclusion we welcome the
secretary general's decision to scale up
the united nations humanitarian
operations in around ukraine
and let me once again reiterate
georgia's unwavering support of
independence sovereignty and territorial
integrity of ukraine within its
internationally recognized borders
including crimea and donbass and
ukraine's navigational rights in its
territorial waters i thank you
i thank the distinguished representative
of georgia
and now i give the floor to the
distinguished representative of poland
mr president
mr secretary general distinguished
delegates
poland fully supports the resolution
just tabled by ukraine
and calls on each member state to stand
firmly behind it
we deeply believe that through this act
we will demonstrate our adherence to the
principles enshrined in the un charter
only by upholding those fundamental
principles
we can see the truly peaceful and
long-term solution to the conflict
caused by the russian aggression in
ukraine
in that sense the resolution we are
about to vote
paves the way to a meaningful diplomatic
effort to end the atrocities
of this war
to achieve peace
poland as a current chairmanship in
office of the organization of security
and corporation europe
called yesterday
for the immediate ceasefire in ukraine
to let humanitarian organizations
deliver assistance
but these appeals for peace are even
more urgent
when you look at the events in ukraine
from a close distance perspective
let me tell you
how we post
see and respond to the horrors of this
world as neighbors and friends of
ukraine
there is no doubt
that we are confronted with one of the
biggest humanitarian crises in europe
since world war ii
in the first three days of russian
russian aggression
facilitated by the complicity of the
belarusian regime alexander rukashenko
we witnessed almost most more than 500
000 people
fleeing ukraine 300 000 of which found
refuge in my home country
we keep our borders open our diplomatic
missions help those who seek refuge in
poland
the nationals of all countries who
suffered from russian aggression
or whose life is at risk
can seek shelter in my country
and i can tell you
only for the first half of today
we welcome people of 150
125 nationalities
fleeing ukraine to poland
so that means it concerns us all
the release of these nationalities are
too long to to read to you so i just
read the first those uh with more than
100 national nationals uh fleeing to
poland only today in the morning
ukraine uzbekistan nigeria
india morocco kazakhstan pakistan
afghanistan poland belarus
iran
turkey
algeria and russia
this refuge applies also to the students
which i understand is a serious concern
of some colleagues here in the in the
chamber
the students are also welcome to poland
and they are offered to continue this
these
studies in poland
we know that some of the missions here
in new york were targeted by the
disinformation suggesting discriminatory
practices on the at the polish ukrainian
border based on race and religion
i can tell you this is a complete lie
and a terrible insult to us
besides giving refuge poland delivers to
those who suffer a very practical and
tangible help
my government organized a special trains
for the elderly and mothers with small
babies as well as convoys with supplies
and medical aid
there are 7 000 beds in 20 hospitals
ready for those wounded and sick and i
want to announce that the first
ukrainian refugee babies were born in
poland in the first twenty-first in the
last 24 hours
and the first life-saving operations
were carried out for the elderly in our
hospitals
poland stands ready to cooperate closely
with you and ocha international
committee of the red cross and other
humanitarian organizations to ease the
burden of the civilians targeted by the
russian aggression
but what i'm most proud of
is the outpour of spontaneous readiness
to help by individuals
polish families are opening their homes
to refugees
they offer close food and accommodation
thousands of private cars are coming
from all over poland to pick up those
who crossed the border
on the first two days we experienced a
long traffic jams because of the number
of cars coming out from all the corners
of poland
polish people stand in lines for hours
to donate blood for ukraine
the scale of help was offered was so big
that the government opened a special
website helping ukraine where volunteers
can register and get guidance on those
in need
while diplomats in my mission are
fulfilling our diplomatic duties here in
new york
our family members and friends are
welcoming refugees coming directly from
the war zone
in this conflict
poland may not be a geopolitical
superpower
but we want to be a solidarity
superpower
and this is how we want to change the
grim reality for better
at the same time i would like to pay a
tribute to those ukrainians who defend
their motherland and continue to stand
for their country's freedom
those are not only soldiers but also
people like barcelina
a 30 year old mother of a small of two
small daughters
living in a village near the polish
ukrainian border
when offered a trip to poland by my
family
she answered
i cannot leave ukraine now
this is my country
i have to stay and take care of it
and now she is cooking food for soldiers
and refugees at the border
a similar answer was given by our
diplomats in ukraine
we keep our embassies and countries open
and they keep fulfilling their
diplomatic and consular duties
let me share your colleagues the message
to you i received today in the morning
from our ambassador bartosz czechoski in
kiev
i quote
i met the public ambassador to ukraine
i work in kiev a city the size of berlin
inhabited over by over 4 million people
from thursday morning i have to hide
from the bombing in my basement several
times a day
i work to i wake to exchanges of machine
gun fire
windows are shaking from the missile
donate the the detonations
i am convinced that right now
when you are deciding in new york
hundreds of thousands of terrified
residents of kharkiv nipper zhitomir
mario paul lev and kiev
look at you with hope and faith
in the power of international law
end of quote
and i wish to conclude
by a reference to the warning expressed
by a 19th century russian novelist
feodor dostoyevsky
in his book with a meaningful title
crime and punishment
the message of the book is following
when someone just like raskolnikov
thinks he's exceptional
and free from all our obligations
and therefore feels entitled to
committing a crime of murder
in the end he faces the punishment from
the crime itself
because committing a crime
is already one's biggest punishment
there is no crime without the punishment
thank you very much
i thank the distinguished representative
of poland
and now i give the floor to the
distinguished representative of austria
thank you mr president
uh and as usual austria aligns itself
with the statement by the european union
however we also want to add our voice in
our national capacity because what is
currently being deliberately inflicted
upon ukraine
does not allow us to remain silent
excellencies colleagues
fellow ukrainians
let me start by thanking you mr
secretary general for your clear words
this morning
and these past days
we are grateful to see that the united
nations is there to help those suffering
and in dire need for help
we meet here today to discuss the
russian aggression against ukraine
to discuss the violation of article 2 4
of our un charter
that we meet here today in this room
is a good thing
and a bad thing it's bad
because it means
after several days since russia launched
its aggression against the sovereign
territory of ukraine
we are still witnessing military attacks
terrible human suffering and loss of
life
it's also bad because questions of peace
and security should be addressed by the
security council
as primary responsible for upholding
international peace and security the
security council cannot remain silent
when basic principles of our
international rules based order are
trampled by military boots and squashed
by tanks
last friday however the security council
decision was blocked by the veto of a
permanent member the russian federation
even though 81 members of the
international community supported the
draft resolution of the coal panholders
yes the veto power is foreseen in the
u.n charter but so is the obligation to
uphold u.n principles
if in the 21st century the security
council is blocked in a situation that
constitutes a blatant breach of
international law we should ask
ourselves if this system of veto powers
is still able to regulate our
international relations
yet colleagues
our meeting here today is also good
it's good
that the general assembly is there to
step in if the security council cannot
fulfill its mandate
and it's good that we now have the
opportunity here in this general
assembly hall to raise our voices
to recall
the principles of the un charter
our charter
and to state clearly that we will not
stay silent if the charter is violated
in the most serious way
this
is our right
this is our obligation as members of the
organization
colleagues at the end of this debate we
will vote on a resolution condemning the
aggression of russia against ukraine and
showing solidarity with the people of
ukraine
austria will vote yes on the resolution
and urges all of you to do so also
by voting yes we show the world that the
un is able to take its responsibility to
defend the rule of law international law
and the u.n charter
by voting yes
we show
that
these acts and similar horrifying acts
are not tolerated by the international
community and most importantly by voting
yes we show
the ukrainian people that they are not
alone
i know that for many of us such votes
can be difficult some say this is a
regional issue a european problem
colleagues an attack against one of our
members
one of members of this organization is
an attack on us all
in our interconnected world
our world is one region
cyber weapons strike everywhere missiles
have global reach
the world is not only regional it has
become local
some say we must respect security
concerns
yes colleagues we must everyone has
security concerns ukraine had them and
gave up nuclear weapons and trusted that
others
would not harm them
but clearly if you have cons security
concerns
solve them with dialogue
not tanks
if a country with one of the largest
armies and nuclear arsenals feels
insecure it should seek cooperation
dialogue
disarmament
and not force against others
some say
well
well look at others look at these other
instances that we have had
what about past violations
colleagues we know this what a baptism
well
trying to justify evil with past evil
trying to excuse yourself by pointing to
the faults of others
but just because we did not stand up in
the past to injustice and evil
that should not prevent us from standing
up now
yes it's true
others have committed aggressions crimes
and faults
yes the international community has
sometimes shown a lack of unity to act
and yes the international community has
sometimes been too hesitant
but let us not
continue to make that same mistake now
let us start a new era when we work
together and stand up united for our
common principles
let's defend the rule of law let's not
give in to the reign of the powerful let
us vote yes
on that resolution
mr president austria is not part of any
military alliance we rely for our
security on the respect and
implementation of international law
of treaties of custom
including humanitarian law
reports about russian attacks on
civilians and civilian objects in urban
areas are extremely worrying
rockets or missiles hitting apartment
buildings in kiev cannot be accepted
these
these attacks constitute war crimes
under international humanitarian law
we urge russia to strictly adhere to
international humanitarian law in
particular regarding the protection of
civilians in urban warfare and
immediately sees these attacks and
refrain from using explosive weapons in
populated areas
we strongly condemn the use of cluster
munitions which is incompatible with
international humanitarian law and
outlawed under the convention
on cluster munitions
and colleagues
the threat
of use of nuclear weapons any nuclear
threat of this kind is a violation of
the principles of the u.n charter the
implied catastrophic humanitarian
consequences do not respect borders and
pose a threat to all of humanity this is
completely unacceptable
perpetrators and those responsible
ordering these crimes need to be held
accountable the international criminal
court may exercise jurisdiction over and
investigate any acts of genocide crime
against humanity or war crimes committed
within the territory of ukraine
in this regard we welcome the statement
of icc prosecutor khan reminding us all
that his office can exercise
jurisdiction over and investigate any
act of genocide
crime against humanity or war crime
committed within the territory of
ukraine since february 2014.
mr president in the last couple of days
ukrainians have endured incredible human
suffering
in order to help ease the humanitarian
catastrophe
austria contributed
2.5 million
euros to the icrc and ngos and
additional humanitarian assistance will
be decided soon
those organizations valuable work must
be ensured by guaranteeing humanitarian
access
colleagues in some
austria condemns the russian aggression
against ukraine
austria calls on russia to reverse its
decision to recognize the
self-proclaimed donetsk and luhansk
people's republics which represents a
grave violation of the sovereignty and
territorial integrity of ukraine
austria urges russia to immediately
withdraw its troops and stop any further
bloodshed and return to the path of
peaceful dialogue like any member of the
un is obliged to do
vienna is ready to host and facilitate
such dialogue we hope that today's start
of bilateral discussions between
delegations from ukraine and russia can
serve as a first step towards an
urgently needed ceasefire
and colleagues we call on you to vote
yes on today's resolution i know it's
not always easy
many of us have good relations with
russia
we love the culture admire the
traditions and have good russians
friends but a good friend an honest
friend will speak up and say what needs
to be said to do and what needs to be
done
when a friend commits an illegal and
evil act
this is what this resolution is for
imagine for one moment that you are in
ukraine shoes
what would you expect from the un from
this general assembly
if you were in ukraine's place
in this dark hour it is our moral our
legal obligation to condemn the
violations of the charter and show
solidarity with the victim of an
aggression
austrian
i thank the distinguished representative
of austria
i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative of czech
republic
mr president
mr secretary general
excellencies
the czech republic aligns itself with
the eu statement
and wishes to add the following
in its national capacity
let me begin with the most important
words
i can say here today
we urge russia to stop immediately
its military actions
and to unconditionally withdraw
all its forces and military equipment
from the entire territory of ukraine
we are meeting here today
at a critical moment
not just for ukraine
or europe
but for the united nations
as a whole
a permanent member
of the un security council
has started a war of aggression
against a fellow u.n member state
it is a
blatant violation of international law
it is a flagrant violation of the u.n
charter
and its principles
which all we should uphold and abide by
this seminal document
was written
with the express purpose
of averting the scourge of war
russian president putin
chose to reject diplomacy
and multiple offers for talks
instead
he decided
to launch a savage conquest
inflicting untold pain and suffering
on the people of ukraine
there are horrific reports coming from
ukraine
civilians including children
being killed in their hometowns
families separated
hundreds of thousands of people forced
to flee for their lives
mr president
let me make it crystal clear
russia
and its people
are under no threat
from ukraine or
nato
we condemn
in the strongest terms
mr putin's threat of using nuclear
weapons
indeed
it is a very dangerous
rhetoric and only further exacerbates
the overall security situation
nothing
can justify the use of nuclear weapons
mr president
russia must be held accountable
for its aggressive actions
ukraine has accepted the jurisdiction of
the international criminal criminal
court related to genocide crimes against
humanity and war crimes
we will be looking to the icc to
prioritize investigations of crimes
committed in ukraine
similarly we strongly support ukraine's
filing of a case against russia at the
international court of justice
requesting the icg to order russia to
cease
its unlawful attack on ukraine
and to stop russia's false claims that
acts of genocide have been perpetrated
in the luhans and donetsk or blast of
ukraine
mr president i would like to reiterate
my country's unwavering support
for the sovereignty territorial
integrity and independence of ukraine
within its internationally recognized
borders
including the illegally annexed crimea
this is why the czech republic throws
its full support behind the draft u.n
general assembly resolution
the people of the czech republic
stand firmly with ukraine
suffering of innocent civilians in
ukraine has raised a huge wave of
solidarity among our people
humanitarian aid is pouring across the
border and to border regions where
ukrainians are fleeing in a desperate
search for safety
the czech government
local communities
as well as individuals
have offered and provided help to the
people who have left who have fled from
the suffering caused by the russian
aggression
and we will continue to do so
mr president
we deeply regret
the use of a veto by the russian
representative last friday to block the
u.n security council resolution
this prevented the u.n security council
from fulfilling its fundamental role
to maintain international peace and
security
it is yet another proof of russia's
blatant disrespect
for this organ organization
however
the large number of co-sponsors
of the draft resolution clearly
demonstrated the prevailing opinion of
the international community
mr president
russia cannot veto
the reality on the ground
and let me hear echo the words of the
u.n
secretary general
speaking after last friday's vote in the
security council
the united nations was born out of war
to end war
today that objective was not achieved
we must never give up
we must give peace another chance
dear colleagues
we the representatives
of
193 nations gathered here at this
emergency special session of the un
general assembly
have a solemn duty
to uphold the purpose
and basic principles of the u.n charter
and international law
as we are about to take a vote on a
draft resolution which is soon to be
formally introduced
dear colleagues
soon
each and every member of this honorable
body will have a chance to declare
where they stand
on the u.n charter and international law
and quite frankly on the most crucial
matter of war and peace
excellencies
colleagues
i'm making a plea to each and every one
of you
representing here all u.n member states
please
vote for this resolution
vote with your conscience
vote for the end of bloodshed and human
suffering
vote for peace
vote for the u.n charter and
international law
vote for all the good
our united nations was founded to
represent
and please let us not forget
the whole world is watching
thank you
i thank the distinguished representative
of the czech republic
so
and now i give the floor to the
distinguished representative of
switzerland
foreign
[Music]
among
negligee oakland piste
found the promo
in resolution diplomatic parliament
dialogue
la swiss reiter sonoff de bruyne's
office celebration conflict sweat
new
i thank the distinguished representative
of switzerland
i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative of new
zealand
mr president
mr secretary general
today
our thoughts are with the people of
ukraine
as they continue to fight russia's
large-scale invasion
innocent lives lost
everyday lives in turmoil
young and old lives that will never be
the same as innocent people suddenly
find themselves as refugees
the worst part of the trauma we see
unfolding in front of us is knowing that
it was completely avoidable
new zealand is in no doubt that the
conflict in ukraine is a direct result
of the unprovoked and unjustified
actions of russia
and its decision to flagrantly ignore
international law
russia is escalating its aggression by
its decision to increase the readiness
of its nuclear weapons
russia's actions are nothing short of
the acts of a bully
new zealand supports the secretary
general's assessment that these acts
represent a clear violation of the
territorial integrity and sovereignty of
ukraine
and are inconsistent with the principles
of the charter of the united nations
and standing in support of
ukraine we are also standing in defense
of the eu in charter
we cannot pick and choose when to
espouse the centrality of the charter
this emergency session of the general
assembly is taking place as a direct
result of russia's actions alone
its ongoing military aggressions
threaten not only the peace and security
of ukraine
but that of europe and of the
international community
we are here today because the united
nations security council failed to act
last friday
to condemn russia's actions to invade
ukraine
russia's use of the veto
when not when it is not only party to
this conflict but the direct cause of it
is a disgrace
new zealand along with a group of small
states opposed the granting of the veto
to the p5
we have continued to oppose the veto
since its inception
and we may remain strong in our
conviction that there is no place for
the veto and the un security council
with the security council having failed
to deliver against its responsibilities
we the general assembly must now stand
up to play our part
new zealand is a primary co-sponsor of
the general assembly resolution and we
encourage all member states to vote in
favor of the resolution
in support of ukraine
and support of international peace and
security
and in support of our treasured uin
charter
excuse me
new zealand has consistently expressed
our strong support for international
efforts to de-escalate the ukraine
crisis diplomatically
having turned away from diplomacy
russia
must now face the consequences of that
decision
new zealand has joined other member
states and implementing measures to
respond to russia's actions
including introducing targeted travel
bans against russian government
officials and other individuals
associated with the russian invasion of
ukraine
and prohibiting the export of goods to
russian military and security forces
our thoughts today must be with the
people of ukraine
who are now facing a humanitarian crisis
caused by the conflict
we echo the president of the general
assembly's call that all member states
must uphold their obligations under
international humanitarian law
further we the international community
must act now to prevent further
pointless loss of innocent life and to
support those who now find themselves
displaced through no fault of their own
we commend ukraine's neighbours for
their selfless acts of taking in large
numbers of ukrainians and other
nationalities who seek refuge from this
conflict
we acknowledge with a grim sense of
horror
but sadly little surprise
the role of accomplice and facilitator
that belarus has played in support of
russia's invasion
new zealand has also extended its travel
bans to key members of the belarusian
government
new zealand is contributing financially
to the humanitarian response and will
consider all humanitarian options
available to support the international
humanitarian response
we welcome france and mexico's tabling
of a humanitarian resolution in the
united nations security council today
finally
aotearoa new zealand is a proponent of
peace and reconciliation
in this vein we say to russia
act consistently with your international
obligations
cease military operations in ukraine
permanently withdraw
to avoid a catastrophic and pointless
loss of innocent life
take all possible steps to protect
civilians in line with international
humanitarian law
and
return to diplomatic negotiations as a
pathway to resolve this conflict
thank you
i thank the distinguished representative
of new zealand
i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative of panama
on behalf of the alliance
for development in democracy
facility
today is afflicting eastern
yes
i thank the distinguished representative
of panama
i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative of china
immediate priority
responsibility
[Music]
[Music]
mechanism
i thank the distinguished representative
of china
so
i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative of bulgaria
thank you mr president
mr president distinguished delegates
bulgaria aligns itself with the
statement delivered on behalf of the
european union and i would like to
highlight a few points in my national
capacity mr president we have gathered
here today under extraordinary
circumstances circumstances that defy
reason but unfortunately are reality
and that reality is that the russian
federation a permanent member of the
security council
is executing an act of aggression
against ukraine a founding member of the
u.n
bulgaria condemns in the strongest
possible terms this provoked and under
unprovoked and unjustified military
aggression which is in gross violation
of international law and of the
principles of the u.n charter
the illegal military aggression of the
russian federation against ukraine not
only undermines global security and
stability
but also puts the international rules
based order in jeopardy
it is deplorable that the russian
federation used its veto power to
prevent the security council from
exercising its primary responsibility
for maintenance of international peace
and security
however the decision of the security
council to urgently refer the matter to
the general assembly by calling an
emergency special session demonstrates
the resolve of the rest of the council
to do everything possible to address
this serious act of aggression
the fact that for the first time in 40
years the security council takes such a
decision speaks of the gravity of the
situation
we commend the decision by the security
council and now it is up to all of us to
live
up to the responsibility to uphold the
principles of d1 charter and
international law and to send a strong
and unarchivocal message by condemning
the act of aggression in the league
elections by the kremlin
bulgaria demands that the russian
federation immediately sees its military
actions unconditionally withdraw all
forces and military equipment from the
entire territory of ukraine
and fully respect ukraine's territorial
integrity sovereignty and independence
within its internationally
recognized borders
the use of force and coercion to change
borders has no place in the 21st century
tensions and conflicts should be
resolved exclusively to dialogue and
diplomacy
we strongly condemn the involvement of
belarus in this aggression
including by providing its territory to
be used as launching ground for the
russian aggression and call on it to
refrain from such action and to abide by
its international obligations
the reports of civilian casualties
including of children and the
destructions of civilian infrastructure
including critical infrastructure are
deeply concerning
we are particularly outraged by the use
of weapons that have indiscriminate
effect in residential areas and against
the civilian population this is
unacceptable and must stop immediately
we call on the russian federation to
fully respect international humanitarian
law and international human rights law
and to allow safe and unhindered
humanitarian access and assistance to
all persons in need
the russian federation's regeneration
bears full responsibility for this
aggression and all the destruction and
loss of life and the leadership
of the russian federation should and
will be held accountable in accordance
with international law
mr president
colleagues it is our duty to do the
right thing we need to stand together
aggressed any act of aggression and
against any violation of d1 charter
we need to fiercely defend the
principles of the u1 charter
international law and the rules based
order because they are our only
guarantee for peace
we cannot turn a blind eye when a
blatant act of aggression is being
executed against the sovereign peace
loving nation
today it is against ukraine tomorrow it
could be against any one of us
in conclusion i would like to reiterate
bulgaria's unwavering support for the
sovereignty independence unity and
territorial integrity of ukraine within
its internationally recognized borders i
would also like to thank the ukrainian
people for their extraordinary courage
and resilience you're not alone thank
you
i thank the distinguished representative
of bulgaria
i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative of italy
mr president
mr secretary general dear colleagues
italy aligns itself with the statement
of the european union and wishes to add
the following remarks in its national
capacity
we do welcome the convening of this
special emergency session
following the impossibility for the
security council to discharge its duties
and adopt its own resolution on the
matter
due to the veto of the russian
federation the general assembly had an
obligation to make its voice heard
in front of such a grave threat to
international peace and security
we are thankful to those members of the
security council that made this possible
italy
together with its eu partners and allies
has made its position clear all along
throughout this entire crisis
with statements and consistent acts
standing firmly in support of the
sovereignty and the guitar integrity of
ukraine
and in full solidarity with ukrainian
people
the unprovoked aggression
decided by russian leadership
is a blatant violation of international
law and u.n charter and
as such it has to be condemned in the
strongest possible terms
the involvement of a betelgeuse as a
facilitator
of the russian aggression is also to be
condemned
in close coordination with the eu
partners and allies we have implemented
unprecedented economic and financial
sanctions
including on belarus
as already stated further steps will
have to be taken if the assault against
ukraine continues
we call upon the russian federation to
stop immediately its action and to
withdraw its military forces from the
territory of ukraine within its
internationally recognized borders
extending to territorial waters
we urge the russian federation to
respect the principles
set in the u.n charter and in the
declaration of unfriendly relations
to abide by the minsk agreement
and to redirect urgently its action
towards a peaceful solution
we trust that the general assembly will
through the adoption of the
table the draft resolution
show cohesion and determination in
dealing with a situation that is
threatening the existence of a member
state
causing a growing number of casualties
including civilians and children
and ultimately is undermining the very
essence of multicultural multilateral
relations
mr president
russia's actions actions are causing
enormous human suffering and triggering
a humanitarian disaster
we express our heartfelt solidarity with
ukraine and its people
and we mourn all the victims of this
miscellaneous
of this senseless war
together with our partners and
building on on the support
it has to be provided since 2014 italy
is scaling up its financial and material
support to strengthen the capabilities
and resilience of ukraine
with an amount of around 110 million
euros
in aid credit and grants and additional
contributions
we are also determined to provide
increased humanitarian support to assist
the people of ukraine in these dramatic
circumstances
in this context international
humanitarian law must be upheld
safe and unhindered humanitarian access
must be granted
the humanitarian staff must be protected
we welcome the convening of a meeting of
the security council on the humanitarian
dimension of this crisis later today and
we hope that the discussions will lead
to the adoption of a concrete
deliverable lastly
we acknowledge and support the
statements of the secretary general
in defense of the principles of the u.n
charter
and his actions in support of the
humanitarian needs in ukraine
italy will remain actively engaged
in close coordination with its european
partners and allies and reaching out to
the broader u.n membership
in favor of the immediate halt of this
aggression and in support of the urgent
return to a peaceful path i thank you mr
president
i thank the distinguished representative
of italy
the undermining of the minsk agreements
by all parties
and the discrediting of the security
concerns voiced by russia
prepare the ground for the grace crisis
we are all witnessing
let me be clear however
this situation in no way
justifies the use of force
against the territorial integrity
and sovereignty of any member state
it is it is against the most basic norms
and principles we all abide by
and a clear breach
of the un charter
mr president
it is of our collective interest
to jointly do
all we can
to stop and reverse the belligerent
actions
before it is too late
brazil reiterates its calls
for an immediate ceasefire in ukraine
as well as for full respect for
international humanitarian law
equally important we call all actors
involved to reassess their decisions
concerning the supply of weapons the
recourse to cyber attacks and the
application of selective sanctions
particularly those which could affect
the global economy
including the critical area of food
security
at this moment we need constructive
solutions
not actions that will only prolong
hostilities and spread the conflict with
rippling effects effects
to the world's economy and security
as we speak
hundreds of thousands of civilians have
already fled ukraine
many more will certainly follow millions
perhaps
the destruction of infrastructure has
left people without electricity and
water
damage to essential infrastructure
interruption of basic services including
transportation and access to basic
supplies
the danger to persons with disabilities
the elderly and children
are causes of grave concern
there are pressing humanitarian needs
for medical services medicines
health equipment shelter and protection
the prospect of hostilities conducted in
populated areas
compounded by the possible use of
explosive weapons and direct
participation of civilians is also
extremely worrisome
we urge all parties to avoid the
scenario at all costs
bearing in mind the grave risks it poses
to the civilian population
we call on all parties to adopt measures
to ensure the protection of civilians
and of critical civilian infrastructure
as well as to ensure unhindered
humanitarian access to all those in need
and the protection of refugees and
displaced persons
we also reiterate our appeal to ukraine
and russia
to facilitate the withdrawal of all
persons who want to live
leave the ukrainian territory
brazil expresses its gratitude
to poland slovakia
hungary
moldova
romania
and others that are facilitating the
exit of people fleeing the conflict
including brazilians and latin americans
let me also take this opportunity to
express our solidarity
to all families who have lost someone in
this war
to all people left without home
water and electricity
to those who are fleeing in fear
sometimes with nowhere to go
and to everyone who is now trapped in a
conflict zone
desperately attempting to find refuge
i wish to command all personnel
that are now in ukraine
trying to alleviate the suffering of the
population
we know that you are doing your best in
very challenging circumstances
and we know that more could be done to
assist you in your efforts
mr president
few times has the general assembly been
convened
under the uniting for peace resolution
by meeting today
the international community shows its
unwavering determination
to reach a diplomatic solution
to the ongoing conflict in ukraine
a peaceful settlement of the crisis
is not only the cessation of hostilities
it is about creating the conditions for
a greater sense of security among all
involved
it is about rebuilding bridges and
regaining trust
and it is about respect
respect for each other's legitimate
security concerns
for civilian lives
for all countries that do not want a war
for international law
and for the most basic principles that
have guided this organization
since its inception i thank you mr
president
i thank the distinguished representative
of brazil
uh
i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative of canada
delegate
settlement
[Music]
liberty
nation
this is a war surely
that is the president by the desire of
president
obama's collateralism and colonialism
the security
the
this past january
mr president
it was in january of this year
that members of the p5
agreed
that a recourse to the nuclear option
to the nuclear threat
to the nuclear possibility
was wrong
they admitted
that no one could win this kind of
confrontation
just
a few days later
president putin announced
that he was going to resort to this
threat
directly contrary to what he had
promised
signed sealed and delivered
six weeks before
and so here we are
with a war that is a threat
to each and every one of us
through this resolution before us today
we as members of the united nations
have the chance to stand up
to stand up in defense of a free people
and to rebuke the evil notion
that might makes right
and now
we must all step up
and stand up
canada urges all member states to
unequivocally condemn russia's actions
and to vote in favor of the resolution
that is now before the assembly
russia has not been alone in undermining
these foundational norms and rules mr
president
belarus has also violated its
obligations under the u.n charter and
under international law
by allowing russia to use its territory
to invade and launch attacks against
ukraine
belarus is aiding and abetting russia's
illegal war
of aggression
belarus's decision to send its force
into ukraine and to revoke its
non-nuclear status
are all completely unacceptable to us
and completely incompatible with its
obligations under the charter of the
united
nations mr president there must be
accountability for these actions
as russia has escalated its
unjustifiable attack on ukraine its
forces have encircled and shelled
ukrainian cities
targeting killing and maiming innocent
ukrainian civilians children women and
men
they are bombing
civilian
objects hospitals
schools
kindergartens
apartments
and homes
they're looting and forcibly to placing
civilians
many hundreds of thousands have fled
in freezing temperatures
sleeking seeking shelter across
ukraine's borders
there are credible reports that russian
forces are using prohibited weapons
including cluster bombs and imposing
siege warfare on ukrainian cities
this is not news that comes in last week
news that comes in this morning
pictures one can see visibly on social
media as to what is taking place
very different from the wars that have
been waged in the past we know what is
happening in real time and it is
completely
abhorrent
let me be very clear mr president
these are violations of international
law
and they are acts that could amount to
war crimes under international
humanitarian law
those acts
flow directly from decisions that were
made by president putin and his inner
circle
that were enabled by belarus and their
leaders
and carried out by russia's armed forces
and its proxies
these crimes began with an idea
what was the idea
we don't have to invent it
all we have to do is read president
putin's speeches
and watch his declarations
the idea that a group of people are
lesser
unequal and unworthy
of
uh worthy of the protection of the law
the idea that a people in fact do not
exist as a people
that they don't have a right to be
themselves
that they don't have a right to their
own nation to their own country
that they have no right to the
protection
of the charter
the way vladimir putin describes the
ukrainian nation and its supporters over
many generations
fits the description of the idea that i
have described
and it's that idea that lies at the
heart of the acts that
follow because
actions don't come out of the blue they
don't come out of nothing
it all starts with an idea
and yet
with a terrible sense of irony
president putin has perverted the very
notion of genocide
by alleging that genocide has been
committed in ukraine
i must stress
there has been no such finding
substantiated by any u.n
or independent organization
and as my colleague from brazil said
just speaking before me
if there are complaints and obviously
there there have been in this chamber
and in the security council
with respect to the treatment of the
russian minority in ukraine
even if those complaints were fully
justified
they are not an excuse for war
and they are not an excuse for the
aggression that we have seen
ukraine has filed its own application
under the genocide convention
to the international court of justice
canada takes the allegations filed by
ukraine
with the greatest seriousness
as it does the decision of the
prosecutor of the international criminal
court to begin an investigation
into potential crimes against humanity
these decisions are not taken lightly
and they have the most serious of
consequences
but i want to stress
it is the international court of justice
and the international criminal court
that are the places for these
allegations to be dealt with
not the battlefield
and never
by unilateral aggression that's why we
signed up to the charter
we signed up to the charter because we
agreed that we would subject our
disputes to processes created by us
over
many many arduous years and debates
what would be done in the event of a
profound difference of opinion between
states
we don't go to war
we go to the negotiating table
we go to court
we go to mediators
that's how we resolve disputes
the other way
lies madness
canada and the international community
will spare no effort to ensure that
violations of international law in
ukraine are in fact investigated that
evidence is gathered
and that the perpetrators are held to
account
we do so not only out of our conviction
that the use of history
that the arc of history tends towards
justice
we do so
because what ukraine's ukrainians are
being subjected to
is
is horrific
and they deserve better and they deserve
more
mr president if i may i'd like to speak
directly to the brave people and the
government of ukraine
we are quite simply
inspired by you
we are standing with you
and you are not alone
our support for ukraine your country
for your ukrainian democracy
and for your right to choose your own
future in ukraine
remains
unwavering
steadfast
and resolute
canada will do everything in its power
to help you as you hold strong and
defend your homeland
against this terrible russian aggression
together with our partners we will
ensure that president putin and those
who ordered implemented and enabled this
reckless war will continue to face
significant costs
and to be held accountable for their
actions
your struggle
is now our struggle
and we are with you
mr president if i could speak directly
to the people of russia
to the russian protesters who are
bravely demonstrating against the war
who have been met with brutal force an
arbitrary
arrest by by riot police to the
thousands of russian citizens
who have written letters
had the courage to put
to put their name on a letter to the
president of russia
condemning this reckless decision
to all those russians at home and abroad
who are opposed to this senseless war
and you are in the millions
canada and the world we see
you and we hear you
your president
vladimir putin
has sorely miscalculated
he has ignored the democratic
and law-abiding spirit of the russian
people
he has underestimated the brave
ukrainians defending their country from
aggression
with whom you have no cause for war
no cause for hatred no cause for
violence
and he has severely misjudged the
resolve of the world
to stand against him
whatever lies are spoken here today
trying to justify
the unjustifiable
or to explain
the inexplicable
it is president putin's war of choice
that is making
your lives much more difficult
but there is always time
for de-escalation
there is always time for dialogue
and your president must choose this path
should he not
i believe it will show just how much
contempt
he has for you
and for the future of your country
and the planet that we live on
and share together
mr president
we should all say together directly
to president putin
stop this war
stop
this war
stop it
before there is more death
more pain
and more hardship
stop the use of threats
take your finger away
from the nuclear button
and never put it back
for as long as you live
come to grips with the reality of our
time as in more serious and rational
moments
you have done
mr president it is never too late to
stop
it's never too late to make a turn to
diplomacy
to dialogue
and to negotiation
the alternative
cannot happen
so now it falls to all of us
as equal members of the united nations
equality and sovereignty
as i've said before
is what we signed up to
when we became members of this
organization
we need to stand up to the principles
for the principles
of the charter
for the purposes of the charter
and to heal the hurt and pain
that has been caused
by this terrible war of aggression
this responsibility belongs to us
and to know others
we sit here
we have to make decisions
we have to take every step we can the
human footsteps
to peace
to reconciliation
and to justice
that is now our job
in the general assembly
and we must seize this moment
this moment
of accountability
this moment of justice
this moment of democracy
we must seize it together
thank you very much mr president
i thank the distinguished representative
of canada and now i give the floor to
the distinguished representative of
singapore
thank you very much
mr president
we are meeting today in a historic
emergency special session
because the u.n security council
was unfortunately
unable
to discharge its primary responsibility
for the maintenance of international
peace and security
as a result of the veto cast by the
russian federation
which is regrettable
we welcome the convening of this
emergency special session
as it allows all countries
especially the small countries
to raise their voice
to state their views
and to register their concerns
in this universal argument
of the united nations
mr president
singapore has always taken a consistent
position
on the sovereignty
independence
and territorial integrity of all
countries
singapore is a staunch supporter
of the rules-based multilateral system
and of the united nations
the unprovoked invasion
of ukraine by the russian federation
is a clear and gross violation
of the fundamental norms
and of the fundamental norms of
international law
and of the un charter
the u.n charter prohibits
the use of force
and acts of aggression against another
sovereign state
this is a matter of principle
for all small states
and a matter of fundamental importance
to all members
of the general assembly
for a tiny city-state like singapore
this is this is an existential issue
a world order where might is right
or the strong do what they can and the
weak suffer what they must
would be profoundly innermical to the
security and survival of small states
we cannot accept one country
attacking another
without justification
arguing that its independence
was the result of and i quote historical
errors and crazy decisions
unquote
we simply cannot accept such an argument
such an argument and rationale
would go against the internationally
recognized legitimacy
and territorial integrity of many
countries
including singapore
this is why singapore condemns
in the strongest terms possible
any unprovoked invasion of a sovereign
country under any pretext
we deplore the russian federation's
special military operation against
ukraine both its operation in the
donbass region and the broader land air
and sea attacks across ukraine including
on kiev the capital city
we also note with great sadness and
regret
reports of the growing number of
casualties
and the loss of many innocent lives as a
result of this unjustified attack an act
of war
we have taken note of the u.n
humanitarian and emergency relief
coordinators commands
about the scale of the humanitarian
assistance
required to help those affected and we
call for safe and unhindered access for
humanitarian assistance to ukraine and
all those in need
mr president
we reiterate that the sovereignty
political independence and territorial
integrity of all countries
including ukraine must be respected
within its internationally recognized
borders
the secretary general of the united
nations has stated that he considers the
actions of the russian federation
to be a violation of the territorial
integrity and sovereignty of ukraine and
inconsistent with the principles of the
charter of the united nations we agree
with the secretary general entirely let
me repeat we agree with the secretary
general entirely and we support his call
for the russian federation to withdraw
all its troops from the territory of
ukraine and for the responsible actors
to immediately seize all hostilities and
prioritize diplomacy to address all
issues peacefully in accordance with the
un charter
and international law we also support
the good offices of the un secretary
general to be deployed in any way
possible to facilitate diplomatic
contacts and negotiations
mr president let me conclude by saying
that the world is watching us as we meet
today in the general assembly
as members of the general assembly we
have to act swiftly
firmly
and with unity of purpose
singapore is one of the main co-sponsors
of the draft resolution that has been
tabled for adoption in this general
assembly
singapore will not hesitate to vote yes
on this draft resolution
singapore will always vote to uphold the
principles of the u.n charter and to
uphold international law
and i would like to urge all members of
the general assembly to vote yes for
this resolution
and distinguish delegates
this resolution is not about taking
sides
it is about upholding international law
and the principles of the un charter the
united nations distinguished delegates
is being tested today
it is important that all countries
especially the small states
send a clear signal that we are united
for peace
and we are united to defend the
principles of the charter and that we
are united to uphold international law i
thank you for your attention
i thank the distinguished representative
of
singapore
we have heard the last speaker in the
debate on this item for this meeting we
shall hear the remaining speakers this
afternoon i would like to inform members
that at 3 pm today the general assembly
will first hold the 60th plenary meeting
of the 76th regular session as announced
in the journal this will be followed by
the second plenary meeting of the
eleventh emergency special session
at which the debate on agenda item five
will continue
the general assembly has thus concluded
this stage of its consideration of
agenda item
five
the meeting is adjourned